okay so for people who don't know
understand the threat comm you went
undercover for a long time as a Muslim
convert with you Muslim Brotherhood and
Hamas and that's what sort of led to
your investigative report and give the
audience a recap so in 2007 and 2008 I
worked on a project called we call it
the Muslim mafia project okay and I
ended up spending six straight months
undercover with Hamas doing businesses
care I posed as a Muslim convert I'm a
Christian but I posed as Muslim convert
at Doral Hedra in Northern Virginia
this was the mosque where Anwar Awlaki
was the Imam prior to me getting there
and he was big moderate voice of Islam
until he popped up as an al-qaeda leader
in Yemen you got into care before you
start working with Hamas because that's
important because you know I'm on cares
watch list for people who don't know
there's one of the biggest Muslim
nonprofit organizations in the u.s. you
have in the u.s. don't know and I'm on
there Washington so you did get into
care first when I say care I might as
well say Hamas I used those words
interchangeably because care is the
Hamas organization factually for
evidence it's not just my opinion for
the largest terrorism financing and
Hamas trial in US history the Holy Land
Foundation trial care was identified by
the Department of Justice as a Hamas
organization so it's not an opinion
that's just a blatant fact so I ended up
pulling 12,000 pages of documents
preserving them as evidence showing them
that they were involved in fraud
political influence operations on
Capitol Hill and so when you see so many
legislators that have policies that are
favorable towards the Muslim Brotherhood
or care specifically it's because they
work political influence operations day
in and day out right from their DC
offices let's explain this for people
who may not necessarily know why is that
a problem a lot of them just think well
Hamas does some unsavory stuff but again
they're under the thumb of Israel so
they're fighting oppressors Muslim
Brotherhood what are some of the
problems with the Muslim Brotherhood in
the context that an American
organization would be supporting the
main problem with the Muslim Brotherhood
as I testified it from the US Senate is
that they had the exact same for their
own documents and for their own bylaws
they had the exact same agenda as al
Qaeda in the Islamic state so you hear
the term Muslim Brotherhood they had the
exact same
in goal in agenda as as the Islamic
state or al-qaeda
and as far as care specifically or Hamas
Hamas is a designated foreign terrorist
organization that should end the
discussion right there I mean this is a
terrorist organization for the
Department of State so not good people
if they're a terrorist organization how
is care allowed to be on Capitol Hill
directly funding and supporting them are
the million dollar question there's
enough evidence right now to indict care
for material supported terrorism right
now now you remember the timeline of the
Holy Land Foundation trial this trial
was adjudicated in 2008 and the largest
Islamic charity in the United States at
the time it was indicted the Holy Land
Foundation was funneling millions of
money to a foreign designated terrorist
organization Hamas yes so you've got of
care was on the unindicted list and
remained on the unindicted list to this
day but think about the timeline it's
adjudicated in late 2008 Obama takes
over in January of 2009 all the
investigators that were ready to indict
the unindicted co-conspirators in that
investigation we're told to shut the
investigation down by Eric Holder and
they remain on the unindicted
co-conspirator list to this day well and
here's something I want to just to
clarify could go out there a lot of
people say well see that she's a secret
Muslim I've never believed that Barack
Obama the secret Muslim the guy
absolutely wanted to appease the pits a
sacrifice at the altar of political
correctness and he didn't want to be
seen as Islamophobic at that time I
don't think matters I mean I've ever
thought that it matters whether or not
Obama was a Muslim from a Muslim further
perspective they sense the Muslim
Brotherhood couldn't have asked for a
better candidate yeah that was better
president so it doesn't matter if he's a
Muslim or a Marxist the bottom line he
was definitely not working on behalf of
the Republic he mentioned Marxist so the
left politically politically correct
sort of DNC establishment I don't just
mean social justice warriors on campus I
mean Bernie Sanders I mean Hillary
Clinton I mean Elizabeth Warren take
your pick Nancy Pelosi they all linked
on all of names yes I do not like any of
those names they all link arms with
Islam because they see it as a
persecuted class of the day but of
course Islam the religion and the
political philosophy goes against
everything that would claim to stand for
when it's gay rights women's rights
why is that why are people in DC people
in the government who know that this was
an officially recognized terrorist
organization like Hamas why are they so
sympathetic to people who would throw
them off a roof we actually have a term
for that it's called the red-green axis
hard left Marx and socialists working
with the jihadi groups on the surface
their goals are antithetical right right
and yet from the markets Marxist
perspective what do they want to do
think Saul Alinsky rules for radicals
you create chaos so that you can out of
that chaos have a revolution now and
their goal is to have a marxist utopian
revolution the jihadis want to create
chaos and then have a revolution out of
that revolution they wouldn't create an
Islamic state under Sharia where these
two groups agree is that you need to
create chaos then you need to have a
revolution and that's why they're
working together they're both just
looking to create chaos as a means to
their end and maybe they haven't
necessarily realized yet that the end is
very different for both of them they're
both useful idiots to each other
yeah and they actually think that
they're that they are using each other I
would argue that the leftists and the
snowflakes have absolutely no shot at
victory going up the jihadi groups but
you know they seem to think that they're
using each other for right now Susan
well so you and this is more they're
creating chaos it's part of an
overarching plan is it possible I mean a
big part of me just thinks you know
political correctness obviously is it's
it's situational ethics it's a world
view completely devoid of principles
political correctness that's why now we
say people of color whereas colored
people is racist it's never even
remotely consistent do you do you think
that maybe it's just that so many people
are blinded by political correctness and
seeing the threat that Islam or you
think the controllers the people we
mentioned the actual elites they know
they just don't care but the rest of the
folks are maybe blinded maybe uneducated
the average American the patriotic
American American at a gut level
understands that Islam's the problem
there's not a situational awareness a
deep understanding of Islam and Sharia
by the average person to really identify
that there's no peaceful moderate
alternative kinder gentler version of
Islam there's only Islam and I don't
think that we're there yet where the
average person understands that
there is an a moderate Islam a radical
Islam and extremist Islam from an
Islamic perspective there is only Islam
and all Islam calls for jihad until the
entire planet is under Sharia let me ask
you this obviously in the spirit of kind
of challenging you they would say well
see if that's true what about all the
moderate Muslims in the United States
who aren't committing any violence who
don't support this there are plenty of
people that self identify as Muslim but
they don't want to adhere to Sharia the
problem is there are plenty of Muslims
that while they are not actually out
there waging physical jihad from a
Sharia perspective jihadists total
warfare political influence operations
espionage getting on care getting on
television defending jihad statements by
linda's or after the San Bernardino
attacks getting on television defending
the jihadis or their families so this is
total warfare media propaganda media
manipulation even Muslims that go to the
mosque every Friday and pay what's
called zakat one-eighth of all of their
zakat which is a giving that they do
annual giving goes towards jihad yeah so
if some doesn't have to go out there and
shoot somebody in the street or blow
something up to not be supporting the
jihad know that that's a good that's a
good point to make it's an important
lineage because I've said this it is a
there's a jihad against free speech when
I'm said I'm told well you know what you
can't paint Muhammad as Bob Ross when
someone says you can't paint this and
they try to create different rules in a
free westernized society for their
little Enclave now I understand if they
say you can't attack someone for his
name being Muhammad of course but when
only one sect when only Muslims are
saying you have to play by our rules
this is a majority of Muslims saying you
cannot draw our prophet that is a jihad
against my personal freedom and I would
say that novelties tend to be more of
your Lindsay Lohan brand of Islam yes
yeah exactly and then move on future if
there is a proactive jihad against
freedom of speech in the West it's not
just jihad that when we talk about
people being afraid to speak out about
Islam that is the imposition of the
Islamic law of slander that is already
doctrinally a core element of Islam that
you do not speak out negatively about
Islam and so we are implementing the
Islamic
slander in the West on ourselves
particularly in countries in Europe that
are actually like you said people are
going to jail or they're being fined or
they're being arrested for simply
speaking up about Islam that's the
imposition of the Islamic law slander it
starts there it ends with total warfare
until there's an Islamic state and we've
seen that for the last fourteen hundred
years this is nothing new
they don't seem to have any qualms with
actually the Islamic view of slander is
anyone who speaks negatively about the
Prophet period that's not allowed no
it's not an inch of capital crime
against is in Islam look there's a lot
of the more you know about Sharia the
worse it gets and there's a lot of
capital crimes in Sharia Beck is
slandering the Prophet prophet is one of
them right that's the progression
everywhere we have a Muslim population
the progression and the goal within that
community is always to move that society
along until there is total subjugation
under Sharia so the goal of all the
jihadi groups it's the goal of every
Islamic community all over the planet
and they're on different paths in
different stages along that but that's
always the goal
I mean look from a Muslim perspective
everyone is born a Muslim all the
prophets of the Old Testament Abraham
David I mean all of the prophets were
all Moses were all Muslims it was and
Jesus was a Muslim
it was the corrupt and filthy Jews for
from their own words Islamic scholars
own words and the priests that corrupted
these texts and that's why Mohammed had
to come and restore restore the truth
look it's all blasphemy but again
there's no law in Christianity that I'm
aware of as a Christian that says that
that we need to kill people that uh that
blaspheme against it and yet that is
codified in authoritative Sharia that
anybody that blasphemes Mohammed or
blasphemes Islam or all law should be
killed we brought up moderate Muslims
earlier there are a lot of Muslims that
don't want to live under Sharia but
you're bringing down literally a death
sentence to yourself or your family if
you come out and speak about it right
but for most of them to come out and say
that let's just say a Muslim converts to
Christianity and then they come out and
speak about that well they've committed
apostasy in either themselves they are
are in danger sure their families back
at home if they have families overseas
they're in danger so there's a lot of
Muslims that that just don't want to
talk about it they're Muslim and name
only but they don't want to live under
Sharia the problem is from a national
security perspective I would challenge
anyone how can you tell the difference
in other words if Islamic law obliges
Muslims to lie in order to further in
advance the jihad I've been at this for
over 10 years and if I can't tell the
difference between somebody that adheres
to Sharia n--'s
or somebody that says they're muslim and
somebody that's a jihadi it just being
based off their words i can if i start
asking questions and i started learning
more about their background but not just
on the surface right and the differences
is a little more drastic and let's say
someone who says they're a christian but
they're actually a Westboro Baptists
with 14 members and they're going to be
annoying and put a God hates [ __ ] signs
outside of a soldier's funeral which you
know I love this didn't get their ass
kicked any good American does big
difference from blowing people up and by
the way yeah just a fact check you were
correct there is no law in christianity
saying to kill anyone who blasphemes
that's a big notable difference between
the history of Christianity versus Islam
early Christians were killed for
professing or love for Christ early
Muslims killed people for professing
criticism of Muhammad that is how the
faith spread final question what is it
going to take most Americans just don't
believe it we're going to watch this
interview say it's fear-mongering what
needs to happen to shake the United
States to shake Western civilization
from their from their politically
correct funk so they can't see this
acknowledging that we're in a 1400 year
war and we can look to Europe right now
we are literally watching the collapse
of Europe right now of the UK it's our
assessment and understanding the threat
that the United Kingdom short of a
miracle will become an Islamic state
Belgium will become an Islamic state
short of a miracle
just watch what's going on in Europe we
are only a few years behind that people
see all the attacks in Europe they know
it still hasn't woken them up well all I
can say is the more you know about Islam
the more you know about Sharia the more
you realize that this is something
that's been raging for 1,400 years the
Middle East was not always an Islamic
the area it was certainly not it was a
lot of areas where Christians yeah
totally overthrown totally conquered by
jihadis this is nothing new yeah oh the
only thing that's new is that there's a
lot of oil money funding the jihad now
where there was an oil money honeybee
jihad back then and that's why I'm a fan
of a keystone pipeline send them back to
their caves I said hey if you like this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you didn't like
this video you should subscribe anyway
because then you can watch the next
video and what you can do is download it
and leave a comment that's really
negative you know particularly if it's
something like I don't know maybe anti
somatic even though I'm not Jewish or
something about my hair or something
about my weird notes just leave a really
negative comments but everyone else
around connect like big care